alors les séries vous avez chacun votre
favori f2000 france regarder parce qu'on
on a les 30 finalistes alors vous maxime
sait qui c'est mr ben alors on va la
voir miss provence a oui c'est quand
même pas mal brassée voilà moi j'aime
bien elle est belle c'est pas mon délire
ajouté après damien moi c'est miss
ile-de-france amis chinois a pas mal
la salle s'est pas monde et ses
connaissances france voilà pas mal pas
mal
ainsi difficile bach papale c'est pas
mon délire ensuite caroline est
d'incarner pas la dire à jean luc voit
ses miss nord pas de calais miss
nord-pas-de-calais il a pas mal c'est
pas mon délire mais beaucoup c'est pas
tous les navires qu'en ce moment les
femmes ont des liens par mon délire
kelly sexy [ __ ] grâce à être obèses
corps se doit a way les belges dans
cette photo mais en vrai les belles
bosses il alors maintenant c'est la
meilleure photo elle est très belle mais
franchement c'est pas bien de dire jean
me laisse ainsi les 30 ha ouais ouais
ouais les balles non bon alors mon
délire quelque chose benjamin ces geeks
picardie miss picardie fait voir à huy a
pas mal ouais c'est pas mon des biens
isabelle sekiyu miss normandie
oui c'est bien maintenant que j'ai vu
miss pas de calais alors là bas sous les
bras la basse et des chocolats
elle a des poils sous les bras il a dit
mais qu'il est
c'est pas possible l'école est miss
normandie pas mal pas mal du tout c'est
pas mon délire mais pas mal et rokhaya
alors c'est l'appréciation un peu
superficielle vous ne les a pas entendu
parler encore mais comme ça à
l'apparence j'aimais bien miss
martinique parce que j'avais vu âme à
l'afro médaille black à la framboise
génial je veux crépus et frisés là pour
le coup elle les lycées mais j'aimais
bien le où trois juges alors comme ça
vous allez auxerre a taillé en date peu
passionnant qu avec jean-christophe
merci appréciera avec la co patrons
russes préférant vous dis c'est très
bien mais je veux dire un très bon très
belle c'est pas mon délire vraiment dire
c'est pas mon délire alors rien à 30
moi je vous dis pour l'instant moi de ce
que j'ai vu je suis d'accord avec vous
isabelle nom isabelle mais agathe a dit
la tienne
mais ce nombre d agathe allez-y c'est la
même que maxime miss provence non je
traiterai ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais moi non plus j'ai pas
dit la mine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
malik est donc voyons voilà donc voilà
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des lunettes de
soleil
c'est pas parce qu'il veut se la jouer
star du tout c'est moi vous êtes venus
pour vous chine et les deux sont là
c'est pas ça c'est qu'elle me demande
c'est ou provence je lui dis parce que
provence a annoncé sa chef provence et
la côte d'azur haussière s'est enfin
qu'ils avaient réuni les deux genres ils
ont fait une seule est allé pas très
bronzé
pour une fille du sud d'accord il ya une
émission parallèle il y en a bien qui
vous plaît quand même date au oui non
non non et c'est en moi je moi je suis
pas là dedans ses blagues voulu envoyer
quelqu'un d'autre me citer pmp quelqu'un
pour moi me cpmp vous le savez depuis
longtemps et qui sait c'est à blida
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]